hello
hey everybody
today good day
hey hey
can you hear me
let me try to
figure it out with you
there's a Chris also here
I can see his face then this podcast
hi so he cannot be you have to unmute
him or something I guess
foreign
I can ask him to unmute
and I can ask to start video
but I don't think I've repeat anything
because you could do it yeah
try it again oh
thank you
I am now able to start my video
apparently it's not you for babe me it
was the overlay that was telling me that
the video was being recorded
that was not showing and I could not
accept it
thank you
but I still thought it more likely that
you would forbid me
yes yes that's what I would usually do
but
hi everyone
already a lot of people 20 I think we
can wait like one or two minutes more
yeah
people then
[Music]
your cat doesn't want to have you give a
presentation
she's been sleeping all day
but now she hears some things about to
happen
is your cat giving the talk today Chris
um she's helping she's definitely
helping
that's what she thinks of it
does she think attention is what you
need or
because I mean that's like isn't that
cats like Captain Randy is
yeah I think attention is all I need is
the mother here
's there at her knee no no no I was just
talking back to her but that was too
embarrassing for me to not on me to not
mute myself
foreign
so hello everyone uh to the second
session of the the book club
um today Chris is talking about the
second chapter which is text
classification and then we will have
some discussion about that where you can
ask us questions uh Lewis is also here
um
and then we have a second half of the
session where we will talk more about
like how to contribute to open source uh
which will be led by VB
Chris who want to take it away
yes just one second I'm just about to
share my slides
[Music]
um
meow indeed Lewis sorry about the
meowing I hope it's not too disturbing
um
foreign
so thank you everyone for joining us for
this um second session of the reading
group as Leandro said we'll be talking
about chapter two but I figured that I
would not present it because we're
expecting people to have read it I'll
just go through
um a very high level of what I think
this chapter is about I mean it's super
straightforward it's not a fiction
please it's actually a an introduction
to the libraries that you'll be using
throughout the chapters
um
mainly the datasets library the
tokenizers library and finally the
Transformers Library itself so in a
sense and just to be super cheesy about
this this chapter is about the journey
not the destination so it's not really
important that you're trying to classify
at the end it's just something that you
end up doing the most important thing
thing I think that this chapter does and
does really well is to
introduce you to the things that you'll
just be using again and again as you go
through the different chapters so that's
data sets for loading your data sets as
the name suggests
um in our case it's going to be Text
data sets which are going to be
tokenizing using using the tokenizes
library which is a very performant
Library written in Rust that will allow
you to batch tokenize your texts
Transformers obviously and finally
evaluate which is a library that was
correct me if I'm wrong did not exist at
the time you guys were writing the book
so that was something that was handled
by the datasets library
um and evaluate as a way for you to be
able to evaluate as the name again
suggests your models and your data sets
will not be going into that into detail
today but is something that we might be
able to cover in future sessions
um so yeah
starting with data sets which I'm not
going to introduce in the way that the
book introduces I'm just going to tell
you
something super interesting about data
sets something that I still can't get
over which is the fact that
mem mapping is basically magic and this
is the snippet that helped me like
realize it so what I'm doing here is
in the line that says mem before I'm
asking the PSU to library to tell me how
much memory is being used by my system
I'm loading a large or two gigabyte code
data set of basically documents that
consists of code from the big code
project which you might have heard about
and then right after loading the data
set which again is like two and a half
gigs I'm asking the system to tell me
how much memory it's using and when I
run that
uh we'll see that loading two and a half
gigs of
data Text data is actually only using 17
memories of 17 megabytes of of uh of
memory and that's not like a trick it's
not that the data set
um isn't loaded if we go to the cell
here
and just go
stack small and ask for the first
element is actually loaded right
therefore as if we ask for the
10 000 element it's also loaded there
and this is something that I'm used to I
know how it's doing it it's basically
mapping a a file on disk using Apache
Arrow but it's absolute magic
um
another thing that this allows you to do
is iterate over it quite fast and you're
going to trade over the entire thing and
about
four seconds with some variants I'm
assuming
um and on this occasion I want to teach
you a trick
thank you Nicholas
um
I want to show you a trick that I
learned very recently that really saved
a lot of time in a
in a pipeline I was developing which is
one second
so there we are we're batching over the
data set and
returning every batch into this batch
variable and supposedly when you're
doing something with it you'd be loading
some sort of column so let's just look
at what columns there are we have
content average line length licenses
whatever size
um
so suppose your
um pipeline required you to load batches
of size the lists of
this size field what we could do is I'm
assuming this let me
I should have prepared this really
um but
what this is doing right here is that
it's loading the entire
um slice into memory and then off of
that it's slicing the the size column
that we're asking for whereas
something super interesting about the
data sets library is that it has a
select method which
lets you do slicing on disk returning
Arrow data sets so all we'd need to do
is to go select on the data set
um
turn this into a range because I need to
be able to
select every individual row
hold on so I'm doing this right
drag this into a comma so basically just
into a python
range and this should show you that
we're doing the same thing
but it's much much faster now it's this
is a small data set in comparison to
what you'd be dealing with in real life
but going from about three seconds to
half a second that's something that will
really save time when you're like
actually paying to spin up instances on
gcp or what have you
um one super one last Super interesting
thing
um
about data sets is that you don't even
have to write a loading script you can
just read in your the data sets from
your pipelines that exist already which
I'm assuming are mostly CSV Json Json
lines but even pickle data frames that
um
that you have lying around okay moving
on to tokenizes
um
tokenizers are are
um oh Leandro what did you learn
I didn't know this electric
it's it's it's it hit me when I was
um
XML there's actually a pull request by
Albert
um that is
creating a an XML loader
um I think Albert would be very
um thankful if you could try that pull
request and let him know if it if it's
working maybe someone can pull up the
pull request and paste it in in the chat
um
tokenizers
um
I'm not going to go into too much
details about how tokenizers
um work and how you would train them but
this is just to tell you that when you
say that you're tokenizing something
you're actually running running multiple
pipelines over it you're normalizing so
things like lowercasing removing
diacritics
um treating different Unicode characters
in a special way normalizing unicode
that's one step and then you
pre-tokenize because all these
algorithms can actually not
perform on like endless streams of of
toke of of strings which means that when
you want your bpe tokenizer or your
workpiece tokenizer to to be trained
you actually need some chunk of of data
and usually these chunks are things like
white space tokenizers so turning your
endless streams of text into manageable
let's say words that are then turned
into sub words using the module and what
we see here is probably the birth
tokenizer this is an example from the
having Face course on tokenizes which I
recommend wholeheartedly and after the
module itself so here
um
is it wordpiece or is it bpe that Bert
is using I'm never sure
um
and then word piece and then the post
processor which is adding everything
that Bert needs in in order to be able
to do the modeling properly so the CLS
token the separating token and things
like that and this is all to tell you
that when you're dealing with a like a
hugging face tokenizer
um
that you can actually peek under the
hood and see how every single step of
these is actually
um
happening and this is something that
took me a while to understand because in
my mind it was this rust library and I
never knew how it it used to be
um like related to what I'm importing
from the Transformers library right so
to access the rest tokenizer that is
doing all these things you would access
back-end tokenizer which is just
bindings a wrapper around a rust
tokenizer and so to to see how the
normalizing is happening we take our
normalizer from the rest organizer we
can call it on the sentence that we have
and it's basically
um
churned or uppercases into lower cases
let's
save that
because it's meant to be a pipeline so
we need to
call the same thing again
this time
the cree tokenizer
and again we can call Reach organized
string on our normalized sentence
you know this is nothing that you have
to do yourself this is what happens
automatically when you're tokenizing
with hug and face tokenizers but it's
like interesting for me at least from
from an engineering perspective when I
wanted to develop my own pipelines to
understand how these things stack up and
and uh
work
no this is interesting here because this
is super super useful for modeling to be
able to go from these words that the
pre-tokenizer is is um
is outputting to the actual string that
you input earlier so spans from so the
span from zero to five is the word hello
in the original sentence after
normalization this is something you need
to keep track of because you need to
keep track of what a word is what a
token is for things like masking where
you you need to have some notion of of
tokens for example and
and then finally we can
do the same thing with with with the
model but I'm not going to go
um
into that right now one last thing I
wanted
to say about
tokenizer so this is just using the
normal Transformers of a fast tokenizer
and you might think that it's outputting
a dictionary because that's what the
representation is
but if you call type on this that's
actually like magical object called
batch encoding that has a bunch of
methods that you can call on it but I
don't typically do that I usually index
into the the sentences here we have one
sentence so we would still access it via
um
calling the zeroth one and the thing
itself here is an encoding object and on
that you can call things like tokens to
see how it was tokenized you can call I
think IDs to see the actual vocabulary
IDs that the model is being fed
um
so yeah this is me this is just me
rambling about tokenizers because
um they're one of my favorite parts of
the
of the pipeline and then finally
coming to the crowning achievement of
the chapter which is actually
classifying text the chapter goes
through two different ways of
classifying text and again this is not
state of the art is just
something that's simple enough to help
you understand what came before it in
order to
really learn about text classification I
would
invite you to go to the tasks page if
someone could paste that into chat we go
to text classification where we see that
we have
11 000 models that we can use for text
classification we have a wonderful
tutorial by Marvin
um
a very detailed explanation of what
classification is what it can be used
for some some links to the hogging face
course
and a link to the models that are
um
labeled as able to do text
classification so randomly the first one
is a model by Cardiff University
that seems to be
some sort of Twitter sentiment analysis
model
and this is quite fitting and a very
nice segue into
what BB is about to present because
this is super annoying to me this yaml
metadata warning so we are going to send
a pull request to add a yaml header to
get rid of that warning
um
the only thing I know do I know anything
about this model
okay it's suitable for English so we're
gonna add
a language field
to add a tag so that people know that
this is an English model but also very
selfishly to get rid of this warning
um
so I'm going to add an informative title
to my pull request add gamma header
this adds an English
tag
and hopefully someone will get to this
um right back to the slides
last thing I want to talk about is
actually three different ways
of doing text classification in a
setting today where you don't have too
much data you could and I would invite
you to visit these links and links and
learn more about
um
each model I'm not going to go into
detail so you can use sentence
Transformers as feature extractors which
is a library that is very tightly
integrated with hugging face
Transformers
um you can use set fit which is a method
that Lewis
along with people from Intel and
some other places I've been forgetting
developed to do
text classification with very very few
labeled examples and then finally a
method that
um is also sometimes used in the space
which is pet or pattern excluding
training which I invented which I invite
you to uh go and check out and with that
I'll leave you with a few resources that
you can use to get more information
about that and
I think we can move on to VBS part of
the presentation which is
going to be about open source and
contributing to open source
should we maybe do a discussion now of
like the things that you discussed and
yeah maybe if there's 15 15-20 minutes
we switch over to maybe absolutely yeah
cool so I see a question in chat from
I'm sorry I don't know how to pronounce
your name so I'm not gonna
uh do a bad job by doing that
um who does the tokenization step help
ensure that the output in the language
model is grammatically correct
um I'm not sure if I'm understanding
properly but I think that no it does not
it's
it's it does not care about grammatical
correctness it only cares about the
the words that you input and the the
tokens that it has learned to produce
um
so and that we can try to
kenize
a misspelling of
hello
by adding an l
and
actually call
the tokens and
it just split it into hell which is a
word that it has seen in the training
Corpus and the word Lo which is an
ending that it has seen in the training
Corpus but
does that answer how does tokenization
handle numbers and number sequences or
hexadecimal values that depends on the
tokenizer what it was trained on
um I don't know if Leonardo or Lewis or
VB have
something to add there but
yeah I mean maybe on a very high level
the way that these tokenizers work is
that for example if you start with like
a PPE tokenizer they start with a
vocabulary that's like as basic as
possible and then you look at like
combinations for example of characters
that appear very often and then these
get merged and you continue merging and
merging until they reach like kind of
like a Target
uh vocabulary size
um and with numbers that means that like
sequences of numbers that appear often
in your training data that they might be
merged so maybe 10 will be a token and
then you you can try
what happens to Japan
and you can probably yeah probably all
like the major numbers they're like uh
a single token so you can see are now
1001 that doesn't appear that often in
the training data so it's split into two
tokens uh maybe another minor thing to
note is like these hashtags
um they're just here to signify that
like the token belongs to the previous
token because we got rid of all the
white spaces right if you just look at
that you don't know whether it's a
thousand white space one or if it's ten
thousand or yeah Ten Thousand and One
and with these hashtags that's just like
a visualization tool to show you that
belongs to the to the previous word
Leandro I can see Ivan has his hand up
would you like to unreason
uh I think everybody kind of mute
themselves
right uh I have a question regarding the
technicization also uh as far as I
understood if I correctly understood uh
Leandro was talking about BT
tokenization there are various kinds of
the communication and
uh other plans to add some new tweaks EG
DP drop out that was introduced by uh
giant Xbox I
don't remember
the authors of the paper but if if there
are plans to introduce something new in
this domain
yeah so I mean
um no go ahead
I mean just like a maybe a general
comment about like what things get added
into tokenizer and Transformers it's
usually if there's like a new model
architecture or a new new model that's
interesting that people want to add then
and there's I think another requirement
usually is that there's like some
pre-trained model that people want to
use
um then this gets out to Transformers
and also similarly to tokenizers but
it's usually like driven by an existing
model that people want to use less than
like here's like a theoretical framework
uh and then the architecture gets ported
without having being able to load like
the preach frame model
um that's like the the high level
um answer to that
um for BP Dropout specifically uh I
don't know maybe somebody else uh knows
anything about
that
okay thank you for me it was quite a
surprise that tokenizer was written in
Rust and and it was awesome happy to
find that something is implemented in
Rusty
cool yeah I think mainly they mainly
want to make it really fast and
paralyzable and I think it's pretty good
at that
yeah I just wanted to add since you
mentioned bpe is that at the moment
um there are three different algorithms
that are supported when you want to
train your own tokenizer so you can use
unigram Alam which is what sentence
piece uses as default in their Library
you can also use bpe you can use
wordpiece and you can do like byte level
for each of them which is a normalizer
in a sense but like is always used in
with the name of the tokenizer
um yes we will share the notebook after
this session
um
there are a few questions maybe I read
one and somebody else can answer it's
like when using a model like birds or
distal bird islamatization stemming and
removal of Stoppers necessary or will
the noise not significant enough to
affect the classification task
um well the words that make sense
statistically for them to be stemmed
will be stemmed by the algorithm you
don't do anything like all the like
traditional what you've seen information
retrieval rule based like Porter stemmer
um like removing ing off things these
these are things that will be driven by
the data itself so it's in a sense you
just have raw text you're training a
tokenizer to find out what the
statistical
um
is that you don't actually
by by uh stemming I don't know what you
exactly mean but like with the tokens
you don't lose any characters right like
in in the original sense it just means
like your work gets split into two words
but you still have like all of the
information in there
um yeah maybe one thing I can add here
too is like the the reason people want
to do like uh stemming and monetization
in more like the classical uh NLP
approaches is that usually
um having a large vocabulary is very
expensive and if you don't do that you
have like a lot of variations for it for
similar words and your vocabulary can be
like a million million uh entry speak
um but with these tokenizers like the
separate tokenizer that we can see here
that usually doesn't happen because uh
as I said before the weight over case
you build up your vocabulary to a fixed
size that you're pretty fine and if a
word doesn't fit into that uh vocabulary
then it will be split into smaller parts
that are also part of that vocabulary so
you will always be able to tokenize
everything and you will not have a huge
vocabulary that's why people don't use
these techniques usually
foreign
would you like to ask a question
hi
um I want to ask so on the last very
last slide you mentioned three methods
for when you have not much data
um pet
um Center Transformers and oh two
sentence Transformers
um when you say low volumes or low you
know amount of labeled data how low are
we saying because
so I I as as part of my day job I train
like multi-label aspect based sensor
analysis models which have like between
40 to 60 classes and you know some of
the lowest classes are like 30 labels
even less than that but we do have like
a few most of them are we have a few
like 100 examples so I'm going up to a
thousand examples but just want to see
from other practitioners like how low is
low yeah does that does that sort of if
you could sort of point to that I know
it's it's a tricky question
if I can check that everyone
um so in the academic literature there's
a kind of convention that roughly eight
labels per class
is uh thought of as being like a what's
called like a Pew shot regime
and this means that you know when you
feed um like you know if you imagine I
have a binary classifier for like
symptom analysis then I have at most 16
examples I can keep my model
um and then usually people then say okay
at around a few hundred labels or per
class
um that's when you start to see the
fine-tuning of Transformers really
become dominant so basically between
eight and like a couple of hundred
you'll see that um a lot of these other
techniques would will do better but then
once you start hitting around a few
hundred per class
um you may as well just fine-tune um you
know bird or something like that
cool yeah
but you're right it's arbitrary I mean
the eight is just because some academics
decided that was important and it's just
a good measure of like you know
um how much data you have yeah I mean in
my sort of experience I've found really
depends on how sort of mutually
exclusive your classes are the closer
they are then yeah and sometimes the
multi-label actually helps to
distinguish the classes just training
all together at once here
should we move on to the open source bit
just to give VB some time I think that
makes sense yeah have like an open
discussion afterwards
yep
Perfect all right and try and share my
screen
okay
let me know if you can see the Halloween
cards
yes yes we can
all right perfect
um so uh this bit is gonna be like a bit
different
um but although uh you know uh important
enough
um
um and and what we're going to cover is
like how exactly do we
um sort of contribute to to open source
right and um this is like this is useful
for
um for you know Holocaust for like
multiple reasons um just taking for
example how uh you know hugging face
Transformers has typically been it's
it's basically been like an
um an open source repository and you
know um any and every new model that
that sort of um comes in just taking one
example
um sort of gets
um added on this
and on within this particular subfolder
of models
um and you know all of these models are
added by and large by the community
right so either the the authors of the
paper or someone who's read the paper uh
they would
um you know sort of uh come in and you
know add some sort of an uh open some
sort of an issue saying hey should we
um you know maybe we look at some good
first issue so say for example this
issue um wherein uh needs over here
um uh says that um you know we should
add swin uh to Sr model right and then
um basically it all starts from an issue
and then we
um we start sort of collaborating on it
we are we are kid and you know um we
raise the pull request for it and then
eventually once everything's done
um this model gets sort of added to
um the main Transformers repo right and
um the main goal here is um is is one to
be want to be comfortable you know
contributing to such open source
projects
um for for both for for pun you know for
fun not fun uh for fun and for profit um
you know
um uh fun being you know just to just to
see how these large code bases work and
you know just to play around with them
uh you know add certain uh capabilities
to um to the way that you're you're
using certain models um that you think
um the community can benefit from and
for profit meaning you know just just to
try and you know um uh make something
um else out of uh whatever's existingly
um whatever already is present in the in
the current repository right
um so um
the
uh this is basically a collab notebook
but just text and what we're going to do
is we're just going to cover like a
couple of basic steps and then I'm gonna
um like open up my uh my server and then
we're just gonna try to create a pull
request and um so and and then towards
the end we also announced some some
giveaways and so on so
um yeah
so um
now that we've established some bit of
motivation behind why
um you know someone should contribute to
open source uh what exactly is
um you know open source
um open source is is basically software
and and like code that is available for
for anyone to freely use modify and then
you know use it based on whatever
license
um um it um it comes under right uh so
um pretty much all of
um the hugging face repositories uh just
taking example of hugging face over here
so that
um we're all aligned pretty much all the
wait wait let's go oh sorry
um all the hugging phase repositories um
are open source so you can you can pick
any so you can pick Transformers
diffusers accelerate data sets uh pick
your favorite and you know then
um use them as you please right
um and then there is also the the model
weight side of it and and you you can
find those on the Hub and you can do
pretty much whatever I'm going to be
covering today we can you can do the
same thing on for like model weights and
you know uh use cases and spaces uh on
the hug and face Hub as well right
um so that that's what basically open
sources right and um how does one get
started with um with open source so it
all starts with you know first of all
like choosing where exactly do you want
to contribute right so there are like
multiple different organizations um in
this one we're taking the example of uh
hugging face but you know um pick your
favorite so there are like open source
repositories from Google Facebook
um also some really Niche packages for
example I know from like audio site
there are something like pie anode um
annotate and you know Facebook like meta
has its own Fair seek um Fair sequence
whatever uh Fair seek if I'm
um pronouncing it right I'm pretty sure
I'm butchering it uh but you can you can
like it all starts from like choosing
which organization and like which
um um which sort of code base you want
to contribute to
um and then it um it it starts with sort
of understanding the code base like how
exactly is
um is the code based structure um so for
example in case of um I'm just gonna
quickly switch to my uh I don't know if
you're able to see that um are you able
to see my uh vs code right now or do you
see this no I I see the collab notebook
uh okay give me one second
okay so I'm just sharing the entire
desktop now
um
so um it all starts with you know
um for example if we decide on say
contributing to Transformers then you
can look at the the various things that
like um
the entire code base of Transformers so
um just on uh just on first looks we can
see that there is an examples folder
which has you know um uh all the
examples of uh how to use
um certain models so say for example if
you want to look at Pi torch examples
you look at audio classification then
you can see that there is a script for
you know running audio
um classification and like there is an
accompanying readme which tells us how
exactly is this
um you know
how what's the intended use of this
particular file how exactly you can use
it what kind of models you can use it
and um and and so on right
um so it uh like once you've once you've
gotten like wee bit of like
understanding of the code base uh then
comes the uh comes the next bit which is
about finding good issues right
um a good way to find issues is to just
go on on a repository um so we're going
to take the example of say Transformers
and then click on issues and oftentimes
the maintainers of the repository itself
would have uh marked what are some good
first issues for you to
um you know
um
get a better understanding of the code
base and you know contribute with
um so let me just search so there is
good first issue and as as I click on it
you can already see that there are like
33 open issues and some of them already
have pull requests so you can see like
some of them have open pull requests but
um some others do not have uh anything
and you can basically like click on any
and then just you know
um start sort of
um understanding what exactly is um is
you know happening in this issue and how
exactly can you contribute right
and um uh once you've um once you've
identified an issue uh it would it would
ideally start with you know
um something like hey I'm interested in
contributing to this issue um you know
um I would I would like to sort of
contribute and then you uh then
oftentimes you would like one of the
maintainers would sort of help you
understand what exactly are you supposed
to do and then you you know get get hack
and open a PR uh a pull request um we
get to how to open a pull request in a
sec
um and and you know then we start
solving
um for the issue right and um that's
that's that's in a nutshell that's what
you know is
um
um how ex that's how you you make a uh
pull request right um so what I'm going
to do now is to just like give you a
Hands-On demo of how exactly can you um
can you do this like with code
um and um hopefully we this won't take
much time and we'll have um enough time
for questions towards the end right
um so so the first step identify a repo
um so let's maybe let's start with
um with Transformers right so uh
oftentimes what you would want to do is
um you would want to go on Transformers
like which is the library that you want
to contribute to and then you you would
want to Fork this repository right so
you click on the fork button over here
and then you choose
um okay so I I already have a fork for
um like I've already created a fault for
it but you would pretty much like choose
your
um your username over here and then you
would create a fork right
um a fork is is basically nothing but
like you creating like think of it as
you creating a copy for yourself of this
um of this repository right um so the
fork eventually would look something
like let me just open my
um profile
would look something like this
[Music]
um
so like you can see over here that
instead of hugging face it has my
username and then you know Transformers
so
um whatever I I do over here would be um
you know
um would be basically separate from
whatever happens in the main repository
and I can then sync and you know play
around break everything in this
particular repository and and then once
I'm happy I can sort of uh raise the
pull request meaning like letting the
maintainers of the main repository know
that hey I have some code that I would
like to contribute and then they can you
know deal with that instead of me
um you know messing around with the um
with the main code base of um the
Transformers type ring right
um so it starts with you know you
creating this um this fork and then what
you would want to do is
um you would want to
um does anyone know how to increase the
font size in code
um you can probably do like control and
plus yeah
wait
uh okay there we go
perfect
oh
sorry let me clear this
um so I'm currently in a
in my research groups server so
um
like don't pay attention to whatever
else is there but
um um so we we what I did was I already
sort of cloned the Transformers
um library because it takes about two or
three minutes
um to um you know
um to clone and so this is this is my
Fork of the Transformers library right
so if I do get status
um
you can see that
oh it's not saying that but
um but anyway like this is this is
basically the um the clone of um my folk
of the Transformers library right
um then
um let's let's try to identify something
uh wherein we can we can contribute
Upstream right so um I'm just going to
make a very simple pull request wherein
I'm gonna take this readme which is
within like examples by torch audio
classification and I'm just gonna add
um you know uh some extra parameters to
um to the to the main file
um over here and then like open a pull
request for it right
um and and let's see how how exactly we
can do that right
um so once you've cloned the repo you
you go into that repo and what you put
in like originally you want to start
with is to
um you know
um
like create a branch so that like
whatever you work on is not on Main but
like on on on like a separate Branch so
the way this this whole thing works is
is we are git git is basically a way of
version controlling your code base so
um like what we do is like main is where
like everything
um which is ready to be used and which
is you know fully tested sort of stays
and then all the feature requests sort
of go in individual sort of branches and
you can like tweak and like play around
with the code base as much as you want
uh in a branch and it would not affect
your main sort of uh main branch right
and um
um that's kind of like nice because then
you sort of Shield your original code
base from all the changes that you do
right
um so then what you would want to do is
you would want to create a branch over
here so you would uh create
um by the way in in case
um you know later on you're trying to do
something you can you can sort of look
at these these commands which I've put
in and um you can just you know try and
contribute via that uh as well so let's
create a branch
um
which is good checkout
iPhone B
um
add
um
CLI argument
and now you you can see that I switched
to a new branch
um over here and if I do get status then
it says that I'm I'm on Branch add CLI
argument right now what I'll do is I
will connect my Fork to the Upstream
which is um which is the main repository
of of Transformers so I'll do
um
I'll do get remote add Upstream
Transformers
um that's done this is in the event
um that we you know that we create a
pull request so it knows that where
exactly does it um is it supposed to
sort of um create that and then let's
let's let's make a quick change right so
we're we're in the readme uh let's look
at the status real quick
um
and so there's there's nothing to commit
right now and then I think within the
readme
um
I
let's make a quick I mean actually let's
just make it uh let's just make a quick
change so instead of like let's update
the warm-up ratio from point one to
point two over here not that you should
do it I'm just I'm just giving you an
example of like how you would go about
the entire process of um contributing uh
to a to a code base that isn't yours
right
um so let's just say that we update the
warm-up ratio from point one to point
two
um over here and then if I do get
um
status
um you would see that it already says
that you know this particular readme
file has been updated right so then we
duplicate add examples
um by torch
audio
readme right then we add a commit
message I am updating
the warm up
ratio from 0.1 to 0.2
and then we do get then then we push
these um these to the
um to our repo
um
origin and what was our
uh
add CLI and underscore
CLI underscore.org
and now you can see that as soon as I as
soon as I pushed it
um it said that you can you can you know
um you can create a pull request for add
underscore CL underscore art by visiting
um this this particular URL so let's
find our way over here
so you can see so um it says that the
base repository is hugging face hyphen
Transformers and this is supposed to go
into the main branch over here uh and
I'm contributing from my Fork of the
repository which is um paper plus 10 uh
Transformers and and then uh you know
from ad CLI arguments
um you know branch and um over here you
can see let me just zoom in a bit
and um you you can already see the
change that I've made um over here and
um for Transformers there is like an
entire
um way like entire PR template so
um uh you know
um look at it like it would it would it
would basically be about like what kind
of changes are you doing in this um in
this particular
um
you know pull request um what all have
you checked have you run the tests did
you make any documentation changes and
like what not
um you you tick mark those and um you
know who all can review you basically
like at the rate those people
um so I'm just gonna just for the sake
of it I'm just gonna add uh
Louise
Lewis here
oh wait I can't definitely not it was
Paul that's not why
[Music]
um
or whatever okay I'm just gonna add like
Leandro over here and I'm just gonna
create a pull request uh please uh do
not merge it um
and when I click click on create pull
request
um
and we did it not today
okay
let's give it a second and so now you
can see that um this entire my entire
changes that happened have now been like
sort of uh now like show up
um uh in in the form of pull request
where you can see like what all changes
have been made to the readme because we
just made that and you know uh what sort
of comments are there and you can also
have like a conversation
um with the with the maintainers over
here
um and uh
you know so on
um before this gets um
before I get a bad rap for this maybe I
uh like I will I will basically close
this afterwards but this is how you how
you how you contribute and then like you
know people uh sort of get uh more and
more sort of um information uh like then
you can have like a conversation with
the
um um with the
um with the maintainers and so on
um afterwards with it
um for example like this and then you
um you know you keep on sort of
commenting uh and and you know making
changes and so on
um for example you know um eventually
maybe we realized that we want to go
from point two to point one again so you
can do the same change and like just
commit another change into the put
request and and um that's pretty much it
right
um so if if this was two
um if this was like too fast for you you
can you can always like look at the
um look at the collab notebook again and
it it has the same sort of um commands
which I used and
um you can basically try and replicate
this um and so on
um one thing that I would like to
mention over here
um is is that once you get like a pull
request merged at least in like
Transformers or or like any of the hug
and face ecosystem libraries
um then you you get a mention in
whichever release your pull request
um gets merged in right so it is quite
quite like gratifying to see you know
your name up there and you know the fix
that you sort of merged or like the
model that you contributed and so on and
uh this goes beyond just you know just
contributing you can you can use these
contributions as a way to show
um the the depth of your knowledge
during like you know your interviews or
you know just to build a portfolio of um
um of you know
um of of tools that you know how to how
to work with how to contribute with and
so on
um
uh now now that you've seen how this
works now it's your turn I've I've put
in a couple of um links to good first
issues from Transformers and data sets
but realistically just just you know
check out any uh of the hug and face
um uh um ecosystem libraries and you
know there is there is a nice sort of
contributing guide
um that that you should definitely look
at it um it essentially like walks
through
um what exactly you know what exactly is
um what what does like a good
contribution mean so like you know how
you know fixing outstanding issues um
you know adding new features Implement
new models um you know fix like examples
or like you know documentations and so
on and you know how exactly do you go
about it um and so on
um last but not the least
um is the fun stuff
um Luis or sorry uh Lewis or Leandro do
you want to talk about the fun stuff
I think Leandro can talk about the fun
stuff I'm not sure
I'm sure I can talk about fun stuff
um so one thing we thought we could do
to make this a little more interesting
is we'll have to read in group every two
weeks
and within those two weeks you you can
go through these like good first issues
or things that interest you and create
PRS
um and that potentially get merged and
you can post the things that you've
worked on in the reading group Channel
and we can we will have a look at the
things you did and every week we can
kind of like Crown the the best PR or
the coolest PR and we have like two
options for swag we can either see if
there's something on the iupate store uh
that interests you like a hat or or like
a t-shirt
um or we also get some physical books
from O'Reilly so if you want like a
physical book
um realistically maybe Lewis and I can
can even sign it uh getting Tom to sign
it is logistically a bit hard
we can just make your signature
yeah which is really good at that
um and then we can send you a copy
um so have a look at the issues
um there there's like a sometimes it
looks like it's very hard to get
something emerged into Transformers
because like such a big library and so
so many people looking at things
um but there are a lot of like
low-hanging fruits to get started
oh sorry
yeah just one one thing I want you to
add like one reason
um to contribute to to to an open source
file we don't need to be how you based
just just any like open source library
in general is that uh it's also a
learning experience because you get like
kind of one-to-one tutoring you write
some code and then a maintainer of like
uh a big Library looks at your code and
gives you tips how to make it better and
to me like code reviews have been like
the main learning Factor like the the
past few years for for coding like I
think that's by far the source where I
learned the most things
so I really I would really uh encouraged
to to try to get into that
sort of you want to say something
yeah I was just going to say like if
you've never done this before my
suggestion would actually be to start
with like documentation
um there's often like
um you know if you look in the docs
there'll be something that's missing and
even really something as small as a typo
um it sounds like okay it's not a
worthwhile contribution but it really is
something that um you know just
gradually improves everything so I think
uh that might be like the easiest place
to start and um then you can dive into
like the more you know Advanced things
like you know either implementing a
feature or fixing bugs and stuff
yeah I mean if people are interested
maybe next week we could also look a
little bit more of what it takes to do
like a code contribution with like
running tests and the CI that's running
I think that's something that we
brushed over a bit but
um it's it's not that hard but uh maybe
it helps if we show it to once
are there any questions any open source
well I missed the first half hour so
maybe you already covered
so whatever you covered so far is it
well
how do I say it doesn't matter whether
you are on Linux or Windows or you are
using collab
um generally not Windows I think has
maybe some limitations uh for some of
the libraries in the hug your face
ecosystem
um but generally speaking colab Mac
should work out of the box
so collab map
Linux Linux and
a Mac
um but
whatever the mechanism you are talking
about you know the
uh to get thing
I I'm a new to git okay I know get I use
some other
version control
system before I know the concept but I
don't know the detail about how you get
okay so
um
all of the get detailed will be
different or not really when you are
using like collab or Linux or whatever
if you if you install kit on Windows you
you'll get something that's called git
bash and it looks exactly the same as
the thing that BB has showed so you can
use exactly the same command and
actually a lot of people I know that use
Windows use git patch because it's like
closer to the Linux version
okay that's wonderful
that's wonderful so next question might
not be related to this but eventually
maybe you will come to it so hugging
face this yeah it's great great thing I
mean really enlightening I mean yeah
is it this thing a kind of a thing for
data scientists to do prototyping and
will the code need to be Rewritten when
you need to deploy it I mean I I would
rather I prefer if you can minimize the
rewriting of the code when you deploy I
mean I know the answer is always depend
it always depends of course
but I want to say I want to ask this
depends I mean what kind of scenario you
have I mean if you want to cover it in
later session you know you don't have to
talk about today and we can I can wait
I mean maybe a quick answer is that um
like at hugging face we have the hunting
face Hub which is kind of like the layer
that connects the whole open source
ecosystem and it's not just the
homeopace ecosystem we have Integrations
with other libraries like the pytorch
image models
um things in audio processing stuff like
this and the basic idea is that for most
machine learning projects there's kind
of like this you know iterative cycle of
you know having data sets creating data
sets then training models then deploying
those models then inspecting the models
building demos all that kind of stuff
and so at some level the hugging Pace um
platform of the Hub is that kind of
layer where you can do all those things
um roughly independent of the domain
that you're working in
um but I think we can probably cover
those things in a bit more detail
um in a future session because I see
we're kind of getting tight in time and
there's a question here from Jensen
yeah I'm just wondering if um it would
be hard to contribute to the code base
like practically speaking if you don't
have a workstation of your own um I have
a Mac and I have access to
um collab Pro Plus so I can run
everything but maybe actually debugging
and contributing could be harder
I don't think it makes a difference I I
do all of my Transformers code writing
in in a Mac
um basically you just generally have to
check that you can do like you know a
few iterations and if it works then in
the Transformers
um like Ci The Continuous integration we
have a bunch of GPU tests so generally
speaking
um it it shouldn't be a limitation
okay so you kind of just leave it at the
end and then if it passes the tests
you're probably exactly exactly yep cool
thanks
oh I think we're getting to the end
um one thing one last thing I wanted to
mention is that two of us things I
wanted to mention uh one is that we're
not gonna go through the books like
linearity
um we don't have to go chapter by
chapter but you can actually choose
which chapter we want to cover next and
so what we're going to do is in the
Discord Channel we've set up a vote I
think we're going to propose like a few
chapters that make sense not to jump to
like the the last one at the very
beginning but I think we have like some
regular rooms uh what to look at next
and you can choose what's the thing that
you want to discuss next week in two
weeks and the second thing is especially
for for the book part of these sessions
uh we don't want to run all of them
ourselves so we think it's much more
valuable if you also uh get involved and
so in addition to giving like people uh
swag for for like the coolest PR we can
also give people swag if they want to
like run a session next time so if we we
choose a chapter and that's something
that you're really interested in and you
would like to like summarize it for 10
minutes like Chris did or point out
something that's super interesting to
you that's in like that domain and then
you can take over the session
um and
and Lead it and I think that way it's
going to be way more interesting than if
it's just us talking
and of course we're still going to be
there and we can still do like the qray
sessions
so yeah maybe even maybe in practice
right on Discord we can figure out what
to do next uh maybe we do like a poll or
something
exactly yeah that's what I meant and if
you if you want to take the lead on the
session just uh send a message there but
I want to do this
maybe one last thing is to remind
everyone that O'Reilly has very
generously provided a 40 discount on the
book for people who use
um Google Play
and that's been posted by Leandro in
in the Discord in the reading group
channel so be sure to check that out
yeah I think if I remember correctly if
you buy it to like the Google Play Store
you get like a PDF or something so you
don't get like a nice Kindle thing that
you you can can use on your Kindle
um but I think it should be good enough
to read
cool
then in that case thanks everyone have a
nice evening have a nice day and see you
in two weeks
and if your question wasn't answered you
can just post it on Discord and I'll try
to scan through and answer as many as I
can
thank you everyone bye everyone bye
the recording will be operating soon
right